if we're serious about building a
stronger economy and making sure we
succeed in the 21st century then the
single most important step we can take
is to make sure that every young person
gets the best education possible
President Barack Obama is making a big
play to be the education president but
his vision for changing k through 12
schools deserves in half for at least
three reasons Obama might say that money
alone won't fix what ails our schools
but his main fix is simply funneling
more money into a broken system over the
past 40 years per pupil spending in
inflation-adjusted dollars has more than
doubled while results have stayed flat
at best Obama is following suit he brags
constantly about his race to the top
initiative which push States to compete
for four billion dollars in new funds
but he's already pushed over 80 billion
dollars in stimulus money to maintain
the educational status Club in fact the
vast majority of jobs the government
takes credit for saving or creating
we're in education it's not reform its
inertia candidate Obama pledged to try
any school reform that worked yet his
very first education related action as
president was to help kill a wildly
popular and successful school voucher
program in DC the program led a few
thousand low-income residents exercise
the same choice Obama made and sending
his daughters to an elite private school
in DC
it's a pipe dream to think that Obama is
going to do anything to [ __ ] the two
major teachers units with millions of
members overwhelmingly supported obama
and who give ninety-five percent of
their campaign contributions to
democrats the largest teachers union the
natural education association spends
more on campaign contributions than
Exxon Mobil Microsoft walmart and the
afl-cio combined which might explain why
the centerpiece of Obama's reform plan
is to hire 10,000 new teachers despite
the fact that they're already more
teachers per student than ever reforming
education may not be politically used
but it is simple give parents and
students more choices when it comes to
selecting and exiting all sorts of
schools it works for restaurants grocery
stores colleges there's no reason to
believe it wouldn't work wonders for K
through 12 inch pitch and sadly there's
no reason to believe Obama will embrace
that kind of change for reason TV I'm
Nicholas